- Speaking of summer,
there is also another name expected
to hit stages soon,
Menudo.
That's right,
the boy band is back
(audience claps)
as a reboot called,
"Menudo, A New Beginning".
And we've got the man behind the project
on the line right now.
He is a friend of the show
and even stepped in as
for host for me once
when I was sick.
So thank you.
Say "Hi" to Mario Lopez everybody!
(audience cheers)
(upbeat music)
What's up Mario?
- Hi Kelly,
so nice to see you.
Thank you so much for having me.
- Absolutely. Always.
Well, tell us about this Menudo revival
that you're working on.
This is cool.
- I'm very excited about this.
Menudo, for those who aren't familiar,
was an iconic boy band back in the day
before NSync, Backstreet Boys,
there's a picture right there.
There's Ricky Martin on the end.
He came from there.
They've been around for decades.
They were popular all over the world.
Growing up,
I was a huge fan.
You didn't see too many young
Latino boy bands back in the day.
But that's a beautiful thing about music,
as you know,
it sort of transcends language,
culture, everything.
And now,
we're doing a fresh
re-imagination of the group
and it's been really exciting
to kind of put 'em together
and focus on this new direction.
Still honoring the legacy of course,
of Menudo from back in the day.
So we're gonna be very supportive
all the way around.
- Ah, that's amazing to hear.
(audience cheers)
That's cool.
You've been working on this
for like a year, right?
So how did you find the new members?
- Well, we started online, originally,
and then had auditions literally
all over the country,
L.A., New York, Miami,
Puerto Rico even.
And it was really hard
because it was so many great kids,
talented kids, to narrow it down
to our five favorites.
But we ended up with a group
we really like.
They're ages from like 10 to 14,
so they're young, too.
- Aw, that's cool!
I love it, so cute!
So they have, the band
has a new single out.
Tell us about it.
- The new single is called, "Mi Amor".
They're coming out the gate strong,
just exceeded our expectations.
They're great.
We have some great producers
working with 'em
and I can't wait for them
to start performing
live all over the country.
That's a, look at 'em right there.
- [Kelly] So cute.
(audience claps)
- Very colorful in their outfits.
Menudo mi amor!
It looks like they can all be my kids.
(everyone laughs)
- I love it.
Thank you, Mario.
It's always good to see you.
Everybody, you heard it from him,
the new single,
"Mi Amor" from "Menudo, A New Beginning",
is streaming on all platforms worldwide.
Y'all gotta check it out.
They're actually gonna be kicking off
their U.S. and international
tour this summer.
Y'all gotta go get ready for that.
It's gonna be a good time.
We can see live shows, y'all,
remember COVID?
It sucked.
(audience claps)
We can see live music again.
Thank you Mario.